garri tutto alle 2 e zagaria tutto al
lab bello studi legali e benvenuto e
questo nuovo video io sono a maxi
occhiali non mi servono più benissimo
benvenuti e questo nuovo video sono fa
vj oggi siamo ad un nuovo blog draga
prima di cominciare devo dirvi una cosa
importantissima
praticamente è successo che c'è stato un
temporale è assurdo il problema è che se
danneggiata la centrale quella che dà la
linea praticamente a tutti quanti per
ripararla devono staccare la linea tutto
il quartiere è praticamente fanno uno
stacco di due settimane la rimettono
prima la realtà che 12 settimane dopo
tra due settimane ho appena sotto nato
milan detto mi sono messo le mani nei
capelli detto non ci posso credere oggi
ho fatto due settimane di vacanza non
posso non fare video per altre due
settimane c'è è impossibile però state
tranquilli che ho trovato già una
soluzione in questi quattro giorni ho
registrato sette video circa sette video
che andrò a caricare nelle prossime due
settimane ci ho messo un casino di tempo
perché voi sapete quanto ci mette a fare
un video lavoro già detto ci metto circa
dalle quattro alle cinque ore per un
video solo per ora che non potevo
lasciarvi senza video un'altra volta
perché avevo già fatto le vacanze quindi
giustamente dovevo rimediare quindi mi
sono fatto un mazzo tanto lavorato
praticamente quasi giorno e notte per
fare questi video che andrò a caricare
nelle prossime due settimane quindi
ragazzi in due settimane metterò sette
video ciò vuol dire che metterò un video
ogni due giorni è sempre meglio di no
mentre video per due settimane intere di
nuovo sarebbe un disastro
quindi la gara mi sono arrangiato come
ho potuto vi giuro che non ho neanche
idea di come io abbia fatto perché
e impossibile che io ci sia
effettivamente riuscito a registrare già
sette video ma ci sono riuscito ed è
stato incredibile quindi ragazzi sono
riusciti a salvare la situazione non è
migliore dei modi ma sono riuscito a
salvarla quindi ragazzi questo ve lo
dovevo dire prima del blog perché è una
cosa molto importante
quindi ragazzi l'alternanza dei video
inizierà da questa settimana che arriva
a partire da martedì martedì perché
lunedì non metto video non lo metto
lunedì ma lo metto martedì non lo metto
mercoledì ma lo metto giovedì e in
alternanza ragazzi questo durerà fino a
domenica prossima per farmi perdonare di
questo anche se effettivamente non è
colpa mia
vi dico che al mio ritorno di un video
al giorno quindi il 24 25
se abbiamo raggiunto i 150 mila iscritti
ci sarà uno speciale ragazzi che mi
state chiedendo da un casino di tempo e
spero che vi piacerà
ricordatevi che il 25 di agosto quando
ripartiremo con un video al giorno
partiremo con lo speciale 150 mila
iscritti quindi ragazzi direi di passare
alla prossima news prima di rispondere
alle domande
molti di voi mi hanno chiesto che cosa
significasse questa pagina su instagram
che ho messo sulla su instagram
praticamente avevo postato una foto di
questa che è la poiché è una delle otto
pagine dello slider ma voi non avete
visto che ci sono anche queste ragazze
sono le pagine dello slider che ho che
ho fatto io anzi noi abbiamo fatto noi
il prelievo il tesoro stato in vacanza
due settimane in montagna praticamente
ragazzi li in montagna di notte
c'è un ambientazione che è uguale
identica slider quindi e fa paura allo
stesso modo quindi mi è venuto in mente
ma perché lo facciamo delle pagine le
apprendiamo sugli alberi sono pazzo
ragazzi lo so che sono pazzo sapete che
se mediamente sarebbero il dietro le
quinte è già praticamente ho preso un
berretto attaccato il cellulare con lo
scotch al mio berretto non sono messi in
testa sono andate in giro così voglio
vedere la visuale mia capri ha intaccato
dalle pagine agli alberi e ho aspettato
che scendessero notte per me
situazione lo slider me la parola alla
mia ragazza che si è vestita di
veramente sei vestita con lo smoking e
tutto il resto è riuscita la cosa che ho
abbastanza carina mi sono divertito un
casino vi sarà anche un po cagato
addosso sinceramente un che stato
fantastico comunque ragazzi nel caso è
venuto bene lo caricherò dopo queste due
settimane quindi vedremo
questo per rispondere a tutti quelli che
mi hanno scritto come avevamo fatto ad
avere la pagina dello slang all ultima
cosa prima di iniziare a rispondere alle
domande
per quanto riguarda il punto possa sono
andato a chiedere è praticamente nel mio
buco di paese talmente piccolo che nelle
poste non fanno il fermo posta cioè non
posso andare a ritirare i pacchi che
arrivano imposta perché la posta è
troppo piccola e allora mi hanno detto
di andare nella cittadina che sta vicino
al mio paese lille invece lo fanno fermo
posta
non ve lo dico in questo video
l'indirizzo ma ve lo dirò su facebook o
domani o dopodomani se tutto va bene
quindi ragazzi per sapere l'indirizzo al
quale inviare i pacchi per i prossimi
blog che apriranno i prossimi blog
guardate la pagina di facebook comunque
lo dirò anche nel prossimo blog quindi
non ci sono problemi
detto questo direi di possono rispondere
alle domande che mi avete fatto nello
scorso blog sfide può fare risponde fa
ridisegna la prima cosa che ti viene in
mente
ok di ragazzi rimarrete letteralmente
sbalorditi eccolo qui il disegno del
secolo è un cavallo se non si era capito
spero vi piaccia aiutato questo lo metto
all'asta martina marchiori fa vi
risponde che il libro ti piace sonno
albero fa vi risponde sono io fa vj non
tu lo sapevi
no tu sei albero sono albero sono sono
al bere fa vj
ciò vuol dire che fa vj è un albero
agi enna colonnetta fa mi risponde ti
togli le cuffie per 10 secondi
[Musica]
va bene alessio mori fari di sponda e
qual è il tuo piatto preferito
questo e c'è anche un motivo perché
praticamente da piccolo
ci avevano sbattuto evidente qui non
chiedetevi come e si vede ancora
vabbè comunque questo white troppo by
wire by wire la fa vi risponde perché
smesso di fare su motori
sappiamo che richiede molto tempo ma per
i 200 mila e oltre allora ragazzi ho
smesso di fare su motori ma non è che ho
smesso di farlo perché non c'ho voglia
di farlo anzi su motori a me diverte
tantissime lo sapete se avesse slave
spread se avreste lo sapete se avete
visto gli episodi precedenti in non lo
faccio più per un semplice motivo
rimette io di su motori gioco le custom
ma povero le mappe e giocate da youth
reate dagli utenti perché le mappe
classiche sono quattro in poche parole
ho finito le mappe da giocare
praticamente se dovessi giocare a su
motori dovrei rigiocare a tutte le altre
mappe che ho già giocato e quindi dopo
un po diventerebbe ripetitivo che dilaga
io lo farei anche volentieri perché
tanto per dopo cinque ore per fare un
video quindi per me magari sei per su
motori non mi cambia di molto comunque
non lo faccio perché non ci sono più
mappe
se per caso qualcuno di voi sa delle
mappe che io non ho ancora giocato negli
episodi precedenti di su motori mele
manda il messaggio privato o su facebook
la pagina di facebook oppure qui su
youtube nel caso troppo delle mappe
nuove farò un altro episodi su motori di
sicuro ragazzi quindi lo riprenderò
quando ci saranno le nuove mappe antonio
barretta fa vi risponde fuori perché non
ti fai una foto in cui dai un bel bacio
sacchet mario la metti su instagram
fatto grigi totti 97 favi prova la demo
di outlast il gioco uscirà il 4
settembre 2013 ed è un horror
incredibile in prima persona allora
ragazzi
bisogna spiegare un paio di cose allora
outlast è un videogame che sto seguendo
da mesi il problema è che la demo di
outlast è una demo privata c'è in poche
parole non ce l'ha nessuno ho
praticamente chi ci ha giocate perché il
team di sviluppo adatto al quel
giocatore gli ha dato videogame perché
potesse pubblicizzarlo giocandoci sto
provando comunque a mettermi d'accordo
col team di sviluppo per provare a
farmelo inviare se riescono
detto questo ragazzi voglio aggiornarvi
di una cosa allora in molti di voi mi
stanno facendo notare che gli horror
ultimamente scarseggiano e quelli che ci
sono non sono tanto spavento divido
assolutamente ragione di horror non ne
stanno praticamente uscendo di seri
usciranno tutti agli inizi di settembre
e gli horror master diciamo sono quattro
e sono outlast antismog di orphan age
d'or waze e come ultimo c'è un mese a2a
machine for peace che farò sicuramente
farò tutti questi quattro farò una serie
su tutti e quattro per quanto riguarda
invece de doorways e huntsman di
orphanage il team di sviluppo di
entrambi i videogames mi ha contattato
perché è praticamente mi hanno inviato
una copia del gioco perché vogliono che
io faccia un video su entrambi i
videogame quindi prima che esca dei
videogames e farò di sicuro gameplay di
ansmann vide doorways che sono due
horror fantastici mentre per quanto
riguarda un mese a machine paul pierce
quell'uscita e lo farò più amati va beh
si pronuncia un anno pieno di infarti
ragazzi tenetevi pronti fa vi è
complesso a perla di saggezza raga
concludo il blog quiz e vito è piaciuto
come al solito lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
in ogni video tratto nella descrizione
ce ne siete riusciti iscrivetevi indici
li vediamo un prossimo video bene
ragazzi